Moammar Gadhafi's most famous son rally  supporters as the people of Libya rise  up against their longtime dictator in  the midst of the revolution naive  Gadhafi insists his father's regime will  crush the uprising this is our country  we live here without here we will never  ever surrender to those terrorists  Libyan nation is so United now we are so  strong on trial for years later seif  Gadhafi listens to a Tripoli court's  decision via videolink a death sentence  guilty of war crimes and suppressing  peaceful protests was you Gaddafi's  former Prime Minister Baghdadi almec  moody and seven other regime officials  are also sentenced to death by firing  squad others are given life sentences or  jail terms human rights groups say the  trial wasn't fair sigh if Qaddafi will  have a chance to appeal his sentence